il ya environ un nom avec mon épouse
nous allons faire des appareils photo
numériques à nos filles à la louise a
longtemps après connaissons me fier à
mon avis c'était le jour d'après et nous
ont demandé où est mon téléphone au
téléphone elles sont jeunes elles sont
pas de téléphone mais finalement nous
avons réalisé que c'était pas des
téléphones de qu'elle cherchait c'était
les appareils photo numériques
parce que pour mes filles quelque chose
qu'on peut porter dans la main qui
permet de prendre des photos regarder
des photos mais maman et papa appelle ça
un téléphone ou un téléphone il a su
pris un coup de vieux
si je regarde les technologies les
évolutions technologiques qui sont
arrivées dans ma vie à moi
il a certaines qui ont été plus
importantes que d'autres
on peut parler des révolutions
technologiques les deux qui ont vraiment
marqué ma vie à moi c'est l'arrivée de
l'internet et les téléphones portables
les smartphones ces choses n'existait
même pas comme moi je suis né et si on
regarde jusqu'à quel point ça
bouleverser nos vies c'est incroyable
j'ai toujours été passionné par ces
révolutions technologiques
le fait de tourner la page le fait
d'aller vers l'inconnu plein de
possibilités qui s'ouvrent plein de
nouvelles choses qu'on peut faire on
peut créer j'ai toujours baigné là
dedans j'ai toujours travaillé sur les
nouvelles technologies
j'ai travaillé très tôt dans le milieu
de l'internet rétro dans le milieu de
simplification pour les téléphones
portables avant qu'on parlait de
smartphones et du coup ça fait poser la
question quelle sera la prochaine
révolution technologique la révolution
qui va même être une révolution pour mes
enfants à moi finalement enfin mais qui
va peut-être pas être une révolution
pour mes petits enfants
ça va être un oui mais bien sûr et je
vais encore une fois passer pour un
vieux
dont l'année 2008 le nombre d'objets
connectés à l'internet a dépassé le
nombre de personnes sur terre plus
d'objets connectés elle a lancé net que
deux personnes dont l'année 2020 il y
aura plus de 50 milliards d'objets
connectés à l'internet
entre nous on sait pas si ça va être 5
en douceur mais bon beaucoup beaucoup
d'objets connectés à l'internet
je suis sûr que vous avez tous entendu
parler des lances ont été obligés d
objets connectés
finalement les médias aiment bien aussi
un peu comme moi on tourne la page on va
vers quelque chose de nouveau mais entre
nous ils sont pas vraiment compris yahoo
en vain moi je ne sais pas si on peut
sont mais je pense avoir une bonne idée
vu que je travaille là dedans donc 50
milliards d'objets qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire tous ces objets mais premièrement
vous savez sûrement tous où quasiment
tous deux téléphones portables une bonne
partie de vous des smartphones il existe
j'espère comme bien et juste pas comme
ghana mais il existe une multitude
d'applications comme on dit il ya une
application pour tout on n'utilise pas
forcément toutes les applications se
tourner un style beaucoup on utilise
très peu mais il existe énormément
d'applications
certaines sont vraiment très puissant
des super intéressant et certains
d'entre eux pour moi apporte vraiment
quelque chose de très bien par contre le
téléphone mon téléphone portable ce
n'est pas forcément le meilleur format
pour avoir ce type de service exemple
j'aime bien courir je fais je fais des
sorties footing il existe des
applications qui ne permet de connaître
la vitesse avec lesquels je cours qui me
permet de comparer ça avec mes résultats
précédents des du coup mais me donner
une petit signe pas dire un latté quand
même pas aussi rapide que d'habitude et
donc ça me pousse encore plus je peux
même courir avec des amis à virtuel mais
des amis qui sont pas cotées
moi j'ai pas mal d'amis dans d'autres
pays et je lance des concours avec ses
super passionnant j'ai un ami à san
francisco un ami en belgique on a mis à
un ami à copenhague avec qui nous avons
fait pas mal concours dernièrement et
c'est super motivant
par contre avant ça sur le bras j'ai
jamais compris les personnes qui veulent
courait avec leur téléphone
c'est lourd et honnêtement le plus
compliqué pour moi c'est ça honnêtement
je ne comprends pas vraiment pas fait
pour ça c'est génial comme
fonctionnalité mes cheveux s'il veut ne
peux pas je sais que c'est facile de
faire des applications mobiles mais
c'est pas le bon support dont la même
sinon vous allez commencer à voir
arriver des applications ou des
implications pas dans des objets qui
vont reprendre un peu de fonctionnalités
que vous connaissez déjà mais sur des
meilleurs supports avec une meilleure
expérience utilisateur non plus
d'accidents parce que quelqu'un est en
train de regarder son bras autre exemple
il existe des applications qui permet
d'analyser son sommeil
la première fois que j'ai essayé ça j'ai
trouvé ça magnifique parce que c'était
on sait tous que comme le sport est
important le sommeil est important on
n'a pas vraiment une visibilité se sent
bon le matin oui ok on sait ce qu'on a
besoin de cinq terrasses des cafés ou
est ce qu est ce qu un ou deux peut le
faire mais vraiment avoir une visibilité
est encore plus que ça après avoir
analysé son sommeil sur une longue
période et qu'on en a des données de
beaucoup de personnes
on peut donner des conseils parce qu'on
peut commencer à déduire un qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire pour améliorer son
sommeil est donc très scintillation
comme implication
mais encore une fois je suis désolé mais
le téléphone je veux pas trop me avec
mon téléphone et j'ai essayé et c'est
pas je sais tu pas que le téléphone
maman pète comme ça mais il faut les
mettre dans un endroit spécifique dont
le lit il faut les laisser brancher
parce que ça consomme beaucoup d'énergie
etc
et honnêtement on n'a pas envie de faire
ça qu'on est fatigué on est fatigué on a
envie d'aller au lit maintenant on peut
avoir ces fonctionnalités ceux des
autres types de supports moi j'utilise
un bracelet que je porte
nuit et jour et ça me donne les mêmes
fonctionnalités en plus vu que je le
port tout le temps ça me dit aussi j'ai
suffisamment boucher pendant la journée
ça me donne des conseils sa vie prend
même quand je dois aller au lit un demi
heure avant samedi à 1 c'est peut-être
leur on s'écoute pas tout en un mais bon
c'est l'idée est là et ça me donne des
conseils peut dire qu'il faut plus
bouché ou pour mieux dormir il faut
mieux être dans une pièce qui
complètement noir bon moi je viens de
démarrer autrement quand on a rarement
des rideaux donc j'écoute pas vraiment
ça il ya des supers conseil qui j'ai
commencé à appliquer et c'est très
pertinent parce que ça devienne très
personnalisé et ça se passe pas que sur
les données que moi j'ai transmis mais
surtout les données qu'ils ont eue de
tous les utilisateurs
bon après on peut pas tout faire avec
des smartphones avec mon épouse de tous
les ont tous les prénoms sont on achète
des plombes pour les terrasses tous les
ans on fait ça parce qu'on n'a vraiment
pas fait pour gérer des plantes
on fait au mieux j'espère combien euros
s'ils répondent on a acheté dans
l'historique mais sa crème pas dans une
saison dense et très très pénibles est
très frustrant parce que tous les sons
les remplacer on re et c'est donc avec
un téléphone on peu voir pas vraiment un
sous traitant
oui on peut aller chercher des conseils
mais c'est parfois des conseils
personnalisés dans ses génériques et je
trouve que jamais leur aussi chez htc ne
savent pas si j'ai placé la plonge au
soleil ou pas etc
mais maintenant on peut mettre des
objets des tout petits objets dans le
pot de fleurs voire même connecté le
pouls de feurs et ça se peut monter de
ces informations pour un simple moyen de
textos pour thomas il faut penser à
rousset la plante ça peut me dire si le
tiendra que j'ai mis c'est le bon ou pas
moi j'ai toujours le chili rude parce
que je trouve que les tiers à
spécialiser ça me fait peur c'est ça a
l'air super compliqué mais bon ça peut
me donner tous ces conseils là et ça
peut tout faire quand on évite à acheter
un koné d'acheter des plants de toulon
d'autres sections on commence à voir
arriver des colliers prochaine et
prochain au début quand j'ai entendu ça
je me suis dit bon c'est un petit cube
aussi de cette unis il ya 80 millions de
chiens il est plus de chiens que
d'enfants et sequedin terrasson omh un
chat je suis pas de chien mais qu'on a
un animal ce que peut être on tient son
cd détecter des maladies ou des
problèmes et ce qui arrive souvent
c'est qui les personnes voient que d'un
coup le niveau d'activité de l'animal
baisse dans une façon radicale ont fait
dans la vie de tous les jours on ne
remarque pas forcément parce qu'un
animal moi j'ai un chat et le chat dort
toujours je sais pas trop le niveau
d'activité
mais bon boeuf si on a un collier le
connais un peu le détecter moi je peux
pas mais le collier peut le faire parce
que ça peut être assez précis et plus me
dire ah ils obtiendront un souci et du
coup on peut amener l'animal au
vétérinaire
il ya aussi la fonctionnalité qui est de
localiser son chat ou son chien quand on
les perd de vue on peut le retrouver
parce que ça peut transmettre à la
localisation de l'animal on peut éviter
de mettre les affiches dans les rues
surtout les sabres avec une super jolie
photo de son chien etc
il y a aussi un gros problème pour les
personnes âgées c'est que
malheureusement il ya beaucoup de
personnes âgées qui tombe un jour ou un
autre je suis un escalier ou ailleurs et
si la personne la chine n'a pas un
bouton de détresse quelque part à
proximité ça peut être une situation
assez grave
maintenant on va arriver débarrassé des
d'autres types d'objets que la personne
n'achète plus porter et qui peut
détecter la chute d'une personne et du
coup avertir les proches afin qu'on
puisse intervenir à temps
on fait la connectivité le fait de
connecter des objets rien de nouveau ça
fait très longtemps qu'on fait ça parce
que pour les téléphones portables
ça fait longtemps non pourquoi est ce
que les médias parlent tellement de
l'enseigné de ce que j'ai aujourd'hui et
pourquoi est ce que on m'a gentiment
invité à venir ici vous parler de ce
sujet là c'est entre autres parce que le
matériel donc ce qu'il vous utilisez
pour construire des objets connectés à
bézy radicalement ont pris pour créer un
détecteur de chute
on utilise un petit bout de matériel
qu'on appelle un accéléromètre
accéléromètre un accéléromètre coude
aujourd'hui 90 fois moins cher qu'il ya
quatre ans quatre-vingt dix fois moins
cher que les quatre ans et ça c'est
pareil pour tous que matériels donc
aujourd'hui on peut créer sous ces
objets un coût serait vain donc ça
devient accessible même aux startups et
à tout le monde
la connectivité a aussi vu des
évolutions
maintenant on peut voir la connectivité
on peut transmettre des informations à
très bas coût et avec très peu de
consommation d'énergie parce que si on
doit rechercher le collier d un animal
le détecteur de chute d'une personne
âgée tous les jours mais ça n'a jamais
fonctionné mais maintenant on peut donc
quelques années on va être capable à
transmettre des informations d'un objet
son besoin de piles
nous travaillons actuellement sur des
solutions qui permet de collecter
récolté de l'énergie de la lumière de
mouvement on ouvre une porte
ça génère suffisamment d'énergie pour
transmettre un message
un animal qui bouge surtout un jeu un
peu actif sa chaîne à plein d'énergie on
peut utiliser ça on sait pas c'est que
l'on parle tellement de l'internet des
objets aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
extrêmement accessible tout le monde
peut créer des objets connectés
ça n'a jamais été aussi facile après
quelque chose qui n'aiment pas trop
comprendre ce que j'ai dit que je parle
d'objets connectés
non allez tiens qu'on en parle et 50
milliards d'objets il n'aura pas
cinquante milliards d'objets parce
qu'ils les objets sont tellement
intéressant
il y aura 50 milliards d'objets ou plus
parce que les informations qu'on peut
transmettre depuis ces objets pour
tellement de valeur qu'on en a
énormément des données on peut prédire
des évènements des maladies si on avait
tous les données de tous les diabètes et
on savait comment ils ont ajusté les
médicaments et quel impact a eu on va
pouvoir beaucoup mieux aider ces
personnes là globalement le plus de
données en un le plus intelligent on
devient pour donner un exemple concret
dans toutes les grandes villes du monde
ont entre 20 et 30 % de la circulation
est due à la recherche d'une caste et
parkings disponibles 20 à 30%
vous connaissez tous la situation on va
un rendez vous à une conférence ted où
on rentre du travail et on sait pas
combien de temps ça va prendre on
cherche une place c'est frustrant
énervant il à la pollution qui va avec
aussi on peut faire quelque chose pour
réduire ces 20 à 30%
ça peut vraiment avoir un impact énorme
sur nos vies mais je trouve que c'est
possible parce que maintenant qu'on peut
déployer des objets connectés en masse
vraiment pas cher on peut avoir ce qu'on
appelle la poussière à une sélection de
où on réalité c'est pas les objets qui
sont intéressants c'est l'information
que ça remonte si tous les places de
parking dont le république de toulouse
étaient connectés tous les places et que
toutes les places pouvait tout
simplement dire je suis disponible
je suis pas disponible vraiment simple
comme connectivité mais le bonheur qu'il
y a à partir du moment où on a cette
information peut toutes les plaintes les
places de parking ça veut dire qu'on
peut nous guider directement on arrive
dans une place de parking disponibles
on ne peut pas réserver la place parce
que c'est dans leur public
mais grâce à toutes ces données là et l
historique
on va pouvoir prédire à quelle place sur
1 disponible comme vous vous allez
arriver là où avec au moins 95% de
sécurité on peut guider la personne vers
une rue où il est au moins cinq places
comme vous devez être disponible à 95
pression comme ça on est quasiment 100%
sûr qu'on va trouver une place bon si tu
sais que quelques sections bhl pour
vraiment illustré que ce qui est
important quand on parle des objets
connectés c'est les informations que ça
peut remonter
pas mal hein quand j'étais enfant
j'étais passionné par superman vraiment
vraiment et ce n'est pas seulement
pas seulement parce qu'il finissait avec
la plus belle femme
c'était pas mal aussi et qu'il était
très fort c'était pas mal aussi mais je
suis trouvée excitant le fait qu' il
avait des cinq formations que nous en a
pas il avait cette capacité à regarder
au travers du mur tenteront de quelqu'un
qui était en détresse est loin de lui on
fait son cerveau était construit comme
les nôtres deux hémisphères limiterait à
droite qui récolte des données des
informations de tous les capteurs tous
les cinq sens qui transfère ces données
au travers des fibres le corps calleux
vers l'hémisphère à gauche l'hémisphère
gauche va donc mâché ces données là les
mettre dans un contexte et réagir ou pas
par rapport à ces nouvelles informations
mais pour moi c'est ça l'enseigné des
succès ou des objets connectés c'est ça
non seulement est ce que vont pouvoir
prendre des décisions à partir des cinq
formations qu'on récolte au travers de
nos cinq sens de nos capteurs monde va
pouvoir prendre les meilleures décisions
parce qu'on aura également plein
d'autres types d'informations sur le
monde autour de nous dans les objets
connectés vont nous donner ce sixième
sens merci